welcome to the man of recaps this is the
walking dead seasons 1 through 10
leading up to the 11th and final season
that's right the first part of the
walking dead's final season is almost
here and it looks like it's going to be
epic if you've ever been a fan of the
show now is the time to get back into it
so get caught up with this recap then
sign up for amc plus click the link in
the description to start your free trial
and join in for the beginning of the end
of the walking dead now on to the recap
meet rick grimes he's a cop down in
georgia who one day gets shot in the
line of duty and winds up in a coma when
he wakes up civilization has collapsed
and the dead are a walk-in yes he slept
right through the zombie apocalypse he
goes home to find his family instead he
meets morgan jones a nice guy who gives
him the rules on how zombies work if you
get bit you turn into one head shots are
the only way to take them out for good
they are attracted to noise though so
avoid guns when possible and most
importantly they never actually say
zombie in this show every group has a
different name for them but our group
mostly calls them walkers so rick says
cool thanks man maybe i'll catch you
later and now works on a mission to find
his family riding a horse into the ruins
of atlanta epic shot turns out though
major cities are not where you want to
be because densely populated areas are
now densely packed with zombies luckily
we're saved by a friendly guy glenn who
introduces him to our season 1 ogs
there's andrea t-dog and merle who's a
real a-hole picks a fight with t-dog but
sheriff rick's here to lay down the law
handcuffs them to the roof to cool off
but now the group is trapped so they
come up with a disgusting plan to rub
zombie guts all over themselves yes if
you smell like the dead the zombies kind
of ignore you more on this later then as
the group's leaving t-dog accidentally
drops the handcuff key down the drain
sorry man you suck anyway merle's
abandoned on the roof this group has a
nice campsite outside the city and
wouldn't you know it rick's family is
here he's reunited with his wife lori
and his son carl aka coral his best
friend and partner shane is here too but
while they thought rick was dead he and
laurie started getting it on now that
rick's back though lori puts an end to
that real quick in this group his old
man dale who owns the rv and mostly
stands on top of it keeping watch then
there's carol the meek little housewife
who has an abusive husband and there's
daryl merle's hot-headed younger brother
who's a real cool hunter type with a
crossbow he is not happy they left his
brother handcuffed to the roof but when
they go down to rescue him he's already
gone oh he found a saw and cut his hand
off to escape one night at camp a bunch
of zombies get in and eat all the
background characters including andrea's
sister amy who comes back as a zombie
and oh it's traumatizing andrea's gotta
put her down carol's abusive husband
though not sad good riddance so with the
camp not safe anymore the group hits the
road they go to the center for disease
control hoping it's still up and running
looking for a cure unfortunately it's
not there's only one scientist left
alive they never even got close to a
cure and the group showed up just in
time this place is about to
self-destruct so our group gets out of
there boom and they leave the cdc a
smoking ruin in season two our group
hits a traffic jam and a whole herd of
zombies are coming they hide under the
cars but carol's daughter sophia gets
spotted and has to run away and they
can't find her they do find a deer but
oh what carl gets shot girl yeah it was
a random hunting accident from this guy
who lived nearby on herschel's farm
conveniently herschel is a doctor well a
veterinarian but close enough to save
carl he needs more meds though so shane
and this guy go on a run to get him but
on the way back they're swarmed they're
not gonna make it so sheen's like sorry
guy i pick carl over you shoots him in
the leg uses him as zombie bait to get
away hardcore shane then shane shaves
his head to reflect his new hardcore
persona so carl survives rick gives him
a sheriff's hat which he never takes off
for the rest of the series so if he is
still missing though so the search
continues and it's daryl who's the mvp
here with his survivalist track and
skills and we get to see his softer side
here he really bonds with the grieving
mother carol these two become best
friends hershel has a daughter maggie
who goes on a run to town with glenn he
finds the last box of condoms and
maggie's like well it's the apocalypse
why not but these two fall in love and
aren't together the rest of the series
then there's a problem when herschel's
barn is full of zombies yeah he doesn't
admit their daddy thinks they're sick
and will one day be cured shane is like
oh hell no and leads the group on a
zombie barn massacre and turns out
zombie sofia has been in there the whole
time oh it's tragic rick and jane argue
over this but shane's like rick you're
too soft for this world there's no good
and bad anymore the right decision is
the one that keeps us alive meanwhile
laurie finds out she's pregnant so she
tells rick about her and shane which was
fair they thought he was dead but
shane's not letting it go laurie can't
take two steps this season without shane
coming onto her in fact back at the cdc
shane got drunk and stepped way over the
line so these best friends continue to
butt heads one day they meet some
strangers who teach him the lesson you
can't trust anyone in the zombie
apocalypse long story short they end up
with a prisoner and the group takes a
vote on what to do with them dale's the
only one who's like we can't kill this
guy we gotta be good people
unfortunately that night a zombie gets
in and bites stale oh r.i.p dale and
eric decides to let this guy live and
shane doesn't approve he takes him out
to the woods and kills him then roughs
his face ups as the prisoner escaped so
they go out searching for him and shane
leads rick to a deserted meadow yeah
he's gonna kill him it's like rick
you're too soft you can't keep your
family safe so i'm gonna do it for you
but maybe rick's not too soft because oh
sneaky knife stabs his former best
friend r.i.p shane but shane doesn't
stay dead what how's that possible he
wasn't bit turns out there's a secret
rick learned back at the cdc that he
finally shares with the group everyone
is infected the bite just gives you a
fever that kills you but no matter how
you die everyone comes back that same
night a zombie heard shows up beats the
rest of the background characters and
our group leaves the farm a smoking ruin
everyone's arguing about what to do next
but rick's in no mood he's like look
this ain't a democracy anymore it's a
rictator ship so in season three the
group's on the road they're really rough
and it's eating dog food but soon they
hit the jackpot when they find a prison
with real tall fences that once kept
prisoners in now it'll keep the zombies
out first they have to clear all the
walkers already inside and our groups
become expert zombie killers now but
there's always danger herschel gets bit
on the leg and rick has to amputate
hoping to stop the infection which
luckily works so life at the prison's
good for a while but zombies always get
in and no one gets t-dog ript dog and
wouldn't you know what the baby's coming
right now maggie's gotta do an emergency
c-section baby judith is okay but laurie
dies r.i.p laurie and young carl has to
shoot his mom in the head before she
turns oh it's traumatizing no coral rex
dramatized two he spends a few episodes
hallucinating lori and is generally
unhinged meanwhile andrea got separated
from the group back at the farm she gets
saved though by someone with a katana
and zombies chained to them what this is
michonne the katana wielding badass her
walker bodyguards act as camouflage
similar to the guts trick and since she
cut out their mouths they can't bite her
one day they're too noisy though she has
to kill him but it doesn't help they're
still found by merle yes he survived and
now has an awesome knife hand he takes
them to the town of woodbury a huge
successful survivors community because
they built big walls and seems like an
amazing happy place it's led by a
handsome charismatic man they call the
governor he's like hey you guys are
welcome to stay and andrea is like yeah
of course in fact these two start
hooking up but michonne doesn't trust
this guy decides to go off on her own of
course she was right he is a bad dude
and immediately sends merle to go kill
her instead merle finds maggie and glenn
it's like hey man sorry about the
handcuff roof thing but he takes him
prisoner and instead of the friendly
welcome andrea got he gives them the
decidedly unfriendly welcome michonne
finds the prison fills the group in they
go for a rescue mission where michonne
finds another of the governor's secrets
he's got a zombie daughter yeah he
refuses to accept she's really gone it's
like don't hurt her but she's like man
this a zombie and all katana this pushes
him over the edge he's full crazy now
and in their ensuing fight michonne oh
stabs him in the eye that's okay though
he gets to wear an eye patch now which
just makes him look cooler merle tries
to join our crew but no one wants him
there except his brother daryl to earn
his keep merle goes on a solo
assassination mission but oh he misses
the governor and the governor does not
miss so when daryl arrives he finds
zombie merle you were a bad guy but
still my brother r.i.p merle and one
episode morgan is back but he's crazy
now tries to kill everyone on site so
now the governor's right into war busts
in there guns blazing but our group's
ready for him and manages to chase him
off the governor is like hey you cowards
turn back and fight but they're like
wait we're not soldiers we're just
civilians but he's crazy and all mows
them all down also we found out andrea
betrayed him left her there with a
zombie so when the group gets there oh
she's bit r.i.p andrea so in season four
the group takes in all the woodbury
survivors most notably tyrese and his
sister sasha we learned the three
interview questions to see if you can
join the group how many walkers are
killed how many people he killed and why
rick's trying to get some farming going
but when a pig gets sick some people
catch the pig flu when tyrese goes to
visit his girlfriend and quarantine oh
someone has killed her and the killer is
carol who hoped to stop the spread yes
carol is no longer the meek house wife
we knew she's a hardened survivor
secretly teaching the kids to use knives
she's like look rick i did what had to
be done for the good of the group but
rick's like yo that wasn't your call to
make you are banished and it didn't work
anyway thus sickness spreads all the
rest of the extras die luckily our main
characters all make it but now there's a
new threat because the governor is back
after the battle he went home and left
woodbury a smoking ruin he wandered the
earth grew depression beard met some
sisters who had a daughter that renewed
his will to live ended up in a new camp
that notably had a tank so he decided he
should be in charge he took the tank and
some hostages over to the prison and to
show he means business oh beheaded
herschel no rip herschel so it's
governor fight round two tank boogaloo
daryl busts out his sick call of duty
skills takes out the tank no problem and
the governor oh katana through the chest
governor is defeated so our group
survives but they're all split up and
they've left the prison a smoking ruin
rick's out of commish for a while and
with no dad rules carl eats a whole tub
of pudding but when rick's back in
action he's not messing around he's kill
you first ask questions later shane
would be proud in fact it's right here
when rick puts on his famous murder
jacket so named because he becomes a
feral beast who bites people's necks out
tyreese made it out with baby judith and
meets up with some more kids and carol
who decides not to tell him she killed
his girlfriend they find a map to
terminus which claims to be a safe place
unfortunately though one of these girls
is crazy and thinks zombies are friends
in fact she kills her sister so she can
have a fun sister zombie friend oh god
what do you do here and it's the famous
scene look at the flowers as carol puts
her down daryl winds up with beth who is
maggie's younger sister she tried to
kill herself in season two but now she's
a hard survivor so far though she's been
a bit of a background character mostly
just holds judith while rick's busy she
and daryl find some moonshine so they
get drunk and have a big fight then have
a good cry then burn their house down
you know as you do they get separated
though when beth is abducted by a random
car and more on that later maggie and
glenn got separated too by the way last
season he stole an engagement ring from
a zombie and proposed cute she's off
looking for him but turns out glenn was
still at the prison there he finds tara
one of the sisters the governor
befriended she's the snarky one they
work together to escape and soon find a
new group abraham's a funny bad-mouthed
military guy rosita's his cool sexy
girlfriend eugene apparently is a top
scientist who abraham's taken to dc to
help cure the zombie apocalypse but it's
like really the guy with the mullet long
story short all our groups find maps to
terminus and reunite there it's a happy
friendly place here have a burger i
promise we aren't cannibals turns out
though they are cannibals and our
group's on the menu so in season 5
things look bleak as our group's about
to be butchered but at the last second
boom explosion yes carol and tyrese were
late to the party and quickly discerned
the situation so carol goes full
commando mode and single-handedly bloom
blasts a hole in terminus that's just
the distraction our group needed they
all escape and leave terminus a smoking
ruin so are groups back on the road
pretty soon they find a priest father
gabriel who's got a nice secluded church
with a bunch of canned food right then
though terminus comes back for revenge
but our group takes them out immediately
abraham tells the rest of the group
about their mission how eugene's a top
scientist they have to get to dc and he
can cure the zombie apocalypse and it's
like wow this is great this must be the
start of the main plot where our group
saves the world our group splits up for
now though because they have to go save
beth beth was brought to a hospital
where doctors and cops are still playing
dress-up but this place is also secretly
devious and she's a prisoner here very
long story short they do a hostage
exchange but beth's like hey you're evil
and stabs her then oh get shot in the
head no they were so close r.i.p beth
the dc mission's also a failure they
immediately run into car trouble and
pretty soon eugene is forced to admit
he's not actually a top scientist he's
just a regular nerd when he saw this big
beefy guy used a bunch of big words to
convince him to be his bodyguard that's
right curing the zombie apocalypse is
not where this show's going the zombies
are here to stay so now our group has no
clear destination they try this one
neighborhood where tyrese gets bit no
they try to amputate but it was too late
to rip tyrese and now our group has hit
rock bottom no vehicles no food or water
wandering the earth without purpose or
direction the imagery of this shot
exposes the duality of the title the
walking dead referring not just to the
reanimated corpses but to our survivors
themselves and in case you didn't pick
up on that rick says it five minutes
later but now we meet a stranger who's
this nerdy justin timberlake looking guy
he's like hey guys my name's aaron you
can come join my nice safe community but
it's like no offense bub the last people
who said that tried to eat us but the
group's got to check it out and so we've
made it to alexandria it's an upscale
virginia neighborhood that's been
totally unscathed because right at the
beginning they built giant walls and
it's not run by cannibals or an unhinged
megalomaniac the leader is this nice
woman deanna she videotapes rick to
document his sexy apocalypse beard
because this place was designed to be
self-sustaining it runs on its own grid
they've got power and water so yeah
nothing devious here just people that
got really lucky rick's like hey they're
all soft if we don't like how they do
things we'll just take it from them they
had to turn in all their guns but carol
puts on an act as the meek housewife
again bakes cookies for everyone so no
one suspects her of unlocking the armory
and stealing some back carl's a teenager
now and he meets a teenage girl enid she
came in from the outside too and is also
having trouble adjusting she has a motto
jss just survive somehow and so
naturally these two form a romance rick
gets a love interest too but turns out
she has an abusive husband but rick's
not standing for that he's gonna murder
this guy in the town square deanna's
like whoa rick we don't do that here but
rick pulls out a gun and gives an
unhinged rant about how they're all too
soft shane would be proud so michonne
knocks him out for his own good so diana
wants to kick rick out but father
gabriel doesn't understand how locks
work so zombies get in but rick saves
the day like hey you guys need me just
then randomly morgan is back he's a
pacifist now who's taking a bow never to
kill again so he fights with a stick the
least lethal of all weapons so season
six begins when our group finds a big
zombie herd luckily they've got a good
plan on how to hurt it away from
alexandria but some loud noises draws
the herd right towards it cause
alexandria is under attack by a group of
raiders called the wolf pack rick gets
back just in time but alexandria is
surrounded glenn is still out there
trapped on a dumpster but this guy opts
for a quick death and like a douchebag
takes glenn down with him no not glenn
oh r.i.p glenn just kidding actually
five episodes later we find out glenn's
okay he hid under the dumpster some more
of our crew is still outside sasha and
abraham start flirting in fact soon they
end up together abraham dumps rosita but
for now they find a rocket launcher
daryl makes friends with the married
couple dwight and sherry but they're on
the run from another bad group and
decide to jack his motorcycle and
crossbow at alexandria the situation's
grim brick and family tried the
old-fashioned guts trick to try to sneak
on out of there but it only works if you
act like a zombie and this kid draws too
much attention to himself gets eaten and
then rick's girlfriend screams too all
her other son blames rick so michonne's
got to stab him but he fires and hits
carl in the eye coral so with the
stealth mission a complete failure it's
time for plan b kill all the zombies our
group are pros but they're getting
overwhelmed luckily just then the
cavalry comes back with a convenient gas
truck and a rocket launcher luckily
zombies are dumb they all walk into the
fire and alexandria is not a smoking
ruin they manage to rebuild carl's fine
too he gets to wear an eye patch now
which just makes him look cooler rick
and michonne living as platonic
roommates but one day it's not so
platonic these two get it on and they're
together the rest of the series so life
is good for a bit and things are quiet
but soon we meet a new character who's a
kung fu master people call him jesus for
obvious reasons he's a friendly guy and
he's here as an envoy from another
survivor's community the hilltop they've
got a lot of food but they don't have
any guns and there's a gang who calls
themselves the saviors that are taking
half their stuff every week rick's like
hey no sweat my people are very good at
killing so they go to the savior outpost
and slaughter them all but soon after
the road is blocked by a couple more
saviors and turns out every road is
blocked by even more saviors this gang
might be bigger than we thought soon our
group is surrounded on their knees in
the woods and it's time to meet the big
man himself it's negan he wears a
leather jacket and carries a baseball
bat loose seal he's a smiley charismatic
type of psychopath and man does he love
to hear himself talk he explains he's
not going to kill them all he needs them
alive so he can take half their stuff
every week but to make a point he's got
to kill one of them right now he's going
to pick randomly and season 6 ends on a
cliffhanger we don't see who it is but
you're watching the recap you don't have
to wait to find out that he picks
abraham no oh r.i.p abraham daryl's not
having this he tries to fight back but
that's against the rules and for his
insolence sneakin's gonna kill another
one no glenn no not glenn he was the
best of us been around since episode one
and his wife maggie is pregnant but
negan don't care he kills him brutally
and so in season seven they spend the
first half of the season at the mercy of
negan's whims you never know if he's
gonna cook you spaghetti or cut your
guts out but finally rick has had enough
it's time to fight back the leader of
hilltop is this slimy politician gregory
but the people of hilltop find a new
leader in maggie yeah she's been living
there since she was pregnant and they
had a doctor and she's proven herself to
be leadership material but we'll need
more allies for this fight so it's time
to meet the kingdom so named because
their leader is the king king ezekiel
who's really committed to the character
of a fantasy king jerry is his best
friend and loyal bodyguard who's just
having fun with it his other bodyguard
is shiva his pet tiger carol's like what
show am i on ezekiel's actually a normal
chill dude though he just used to do
community theater and was a zookeeper
and he's got a crush on carol eventually
these two get together but the kingdom
is also under the thumb of the saviors
and so long story short rick convinces
them to join them there's also oceanside
a coastal community of all women because
the saviors killed all their men so now
they don't like strangers long story
short tara befriends them although they
don't actually agree to help fight our
group kind of just takes their guns then
there's the trash people a bunch of
goths who live in the dump and have very
quickly developed their own strange
culture but rick eventually convinces
them to join too now the savior home
base is a big scary industrial building
called the sanctuary daryl is a prisoner
there for a while and soon negan takes
eugene too earlier he found out that
eugene's a smartypants who knows how to
manufacture bullets he wants eugene to
make bullets for him but ideally not as
a prisoner as a full-blown member of
negan's gang with all the rights and
privileges that entails when eugene sees
the price of disloyalty he's like yup
negan i'm in all the way and he starts
to really enjoy his position of power as
chief engineer another of negan's top
lieutenants is dwight the guy who stole
daryl's motorcycle and crossbow
apparently negan caught them and forced
jerry to become one of his wives and
ex-boyfriends of negan's wives get hot
ironed to the face so that's what
happened to dwight obviously dwight
hates negan but he's been broken there's
nothing left in him but obedience but
one day sherry escapes so dwight goes
back to their home but she's left him a
note i didn't know if you turned me back
into negan so i'm not here and it's
tragic cause he wasn't gonna he brought
beer and pretzels like they always said
they would so after this dwight finds
our crew like hey negan's gotta go down
i'll be your man on the inside so soon
negan rolls up in force to punish their
disobedience sasha was captured earlier
so he threatens to execute her but well
she's already dead yeah she pleaded to
eugene for help but the help he gave her
was a suicide pill but she figured what
the heck i'll turn myself into a weapon
and oh she almost gets negan r.i.p sasha
but now rick has the trash people on his
side but oh they double-cross him negan
made him a better offer and so once
again rick is on his knees and to teach
him a lesson this time negan's gonna
kill carl but oh tiger attack yes
hilltop in the kingdom arrive just in
time chase negan off for now and now the
triple alliance is ready for all-out war
so in season 8 it's zombie apocalypse
warfare time which sometimes involves
just wasting a lot of bullets but
there's other cool stuff like armored
cars and using zombie herds against your
enemies it's kind of a convoluted season
a lot of back and forth but the most
noteworthy things the king's tiger dies
shiva father gabriel loses sight in one
eye and morgan gives up on his no
killing bow he starts killing everyone
again maybe there's a middle ground
there but the biggest loss of them all
is carl he got bit no coal
yes even though he's a seasoned zombie
killer now it's always dangerous
sometimes you get bit r.i.p carl now
they still have dwight as an inside man
and one day he leaked some plans but
turns out negan knew he was a traitor
and gave him fake plans so our group
walks into an ambush and are totally
surrounded now the saviors have plenty
of bullets left because eugene's been
manufacturing them but now at the last
battle they all backfire yes eugene
finally grew a spine and a conscience
and saved the day so our group easily
wins the day rick has his final showdown
with negan the question is what to do
with the other saviors but rick goes
into mercy mode gives an impassioned
speech about how the living need to
stick together because the real enemy is
the dead and indeed many of these
saviors become valued members of the
group like this nice guy alden in fact
rick lets negan live too yeah he
sentences him to prison for life to
prove that they're the good guys morgan
renews his vows of non-violence and
decides to cross over to fear the
walking dead and become the new main
character over there and dwight goes
back to find that sherry liked his
offering of beer and pretzels she says
come find me so they go off to fear too
so in season nine the good guys won and
the future looks bright maggie though is
not happy that negan's still alive she's
gonna kill him but when she sees how
much he hates being locked up she's like
never mind i'm gonna leave you here to
rot so life in the zombie apocalypse is
pretty good now with all the communities
working together until the bridge that
connects them all finally collapses so
rick has got to lead a massive
construction project one day though rick
runs into some zombie trouble and oh
ends up in a bad situation trying to
make it home but instead he leads the
horde right to the bridge he's gotta
stop him from crossing so the dynamite
he's gonna take the shot oh rick grimes
boom blows the bridge and himself up all
the ultimate sacrifice to save the
communities miraculously though rick
survives and in fact he's found just
then by the leader of the trash people
jadis there's been a whole mystery with
her she's in communication with some
super group that has helicopters in fear
the walking dead and the world beyond we
learn a little bit about this group the
civic republic military the crm they're
gonna give her a ride in exchange for a
prisoner so she's like well that was a
freebie so rick grimes our main
character flying off the show on a
helicopter off to a whole new series of
adventures in theoretically his own
spin-off movies we immediately cut to a
whole new group of characters having
some zombie trouble when they're saved
by a little girl with rick and carl's
sheriff's hat yes this is a grown-up
judith grimes we've had a time jump
alexandria is still prospering they have
a windmill now but they're not very
friendly these days they went through
some bad stuff during the time jump in
fact they've been out of contact with
the other communities rick's bridge was
never rebuilt this new group is magna
the hot-headed one yumiko the cool
level-headed one incidentally these two
are dating there's also connie who's
deaf and her sister kelly and luke the
funny music nerd they quickly proved
themselves to be capable survivors and
yeah they're fighting with slingshots
and bow and arrows eugene's bullet
factory didn't work out i guess and now
a decade after the start of the zombie
apocalypse there's no ammo left there's
also no gas left we don't do cars
anymore we're riding horses over at the
kingdom carol has grown out long hair
and is officially married to king
ezekiel they adopted this kid henry
who's been training in morgan's way of
the stick but the kingdom is starting to
fall apart ezekiel's trying to organize
an inner community fair to bring
everyone back together so carol and
henry go on an adventure and their first
stop is the old hermit of the woods
obi-wan daryl kenobi he never stopped
looking for rick grimes he's been living
out here by himself this whole time well
not totally by himself because he has a
dog now named dog eventually we get a
flashback to see how they met he
belonged to a woman leia and she and
daryl fell in love but one day she too
disappeared without a trace maybe
that'll come up later now the hilltop is
also thriving but maggie's not the
leader anymore in fact she left the show
she met a woman named georgie who's
apparently an expert on medieval
technologies and drives around the
country teaching people how to build
windmills and stuff maggie was like hey
i could use a change of scenery i'm
coming with you and big bad negan is not
very scary anymore he's befriended young
judith grimes and is just the funny man
that lives under the stairs but in six
years no one taught father gabriel how
to lock a gate and so one day the negan
is friggin he goes on a bit of a
walkabout but realizes there's nothing
out here for him anymore he just goes
back to his cell later during a blizzard
he risks his life to save judith and dog
yes negan is trying for a redemption arc
now the main problem this season begins
when rosita and eugene run into a zombie
herd but this is no normal herd because
the zombies are whispering to each other
smart talking zombies are they evolving
what the butt our crew ends up cornered
in a cemetery and they are expert zombie
slayers but not when they dodge then
stab you with a knife all these new
walkers are terrifying turns out though
they're not smart evolved walkers they
are just people who wear zombie masks
yes this group is called the whisperers
and they've taken the guts trick to the
extreme they wear zombie faces and live
among them full time luckily they're a
lot less scary when they don't have the
element of surprise and soon our group
takes one prisoner this young girl named
lydia she's like hey please don't send
me back they are awful especially their
leader my mother alpha she's a cult
leader like figure who's been completely
broken by the zombie apocalypse and
eventually we learn the whispers have no
reasonable motivation their motto is we
are the end of the world alpha has
completely rid herself of human emotions
in fact she's abusive to her daughter to
make her stronger but daryl's not gonna
stand for that he's leading a rescue
mission with stickboy henry who in a
very quick time formed a romance with
lydia so on the day of the
inter-community fair everyone's having a
great time including some whisperers in
disguise they end up capturing a bunch
of our group and reveal their true power
alpha has a absolutely massive zombie
horde that her people are controlling
she's like look if you guys cross into
our territory we'll unleash it on ya and
to mark the border of that territory
heads on pikes yes alpha killed like a
dozen minor characters in one fell swoop
but also some bigger ones like enid yeah
carl's old girlfriend who's an adult now
and started dating nice savior alvin
r.i.p enid and tara who's been around
for a long time now and grew into the
leader of hilltop r.i.p tara and say it
ain't so it's stick boy henry tennis
years after carol lost sofia she's right
back here again so now in season 10 our
group is at the mercy of the whisperers
for now they seem to have a cold war
standoff kind of tense peace but more
bad things start happening is this
coincidence or is it the whisperers
leads to unrest in the community silence
the whispers graffiti a lot of this hate
is unfairly directed at lydia so she
goes to another outcast for advice it's
negan yes he's allowed out of his cell
these days for good behavior and he
really befriends lydia here becomes her
uncle negan one night some people try to
kill lydia but negan's there to save her
unfortunately he pushed this one way too
hard and killed her that definitely
violates his parole the council votes to
finally just execute him but before they
can someone's let him out of his cell
negan is friggin once again and now he
goes to alpha like hey they were going
to execute me let me join you although
negan's not a good fit for the
whisperers this guy really loves to hear
himself talk back at alexandria there's
a new baby yes it's rosita's she's
dating father gabriel these days and
somewhere along the line he became kind
of a badass but father gabriel is not
the father it's actually siddique who
rosita was dating before him he's
alexandria's doctor and a real good guy
but he's been having ptsd lately because
he was with the whisperers when they
beheaded everyone and made him watch
luckily a new doctor joined the group
this nice guy dante who's here to help
out but when dante comes to comfort him
he does the tongue click tick which
sadiq remembers the whisperer that was
holding him down also did dante's an
undercover whisperer and he kills him
are a piece of deak one day this season
michonne meets this guy virgil who's
like hey i've got an island off the
coast with a bunch of weapons that can
help you fight the whisperers but long
story short he has no weapons he's crazy
but michonne does find a cell phone that
apparently belongs to rick grimes the
first clue they've had in all this time
so michonne says goodbye to her
stepdaughter judith and her and rick's
son rick jr all so cute mama's going
back into badass mode to bring your
daddy home and so michonne leaves the
show to go find rick which now just
leaves bffs daryl and carol as the last
two standing from the first three
seasons this season carol wants revenge
on alpha for killing henry and makes
some pretty reckless moves while trying
to kill her one day she chases alpha who
leads our group down into a mine shaft
where she is hiding her massive zombie
horde our group finds the exit but carol
plants some dynamite which does not
destroy the herd but does trap magna and
connie this is sad for daryl he and
connie had been really hitting it off
she does make it out by the end of the
season but our group doesn't find her
yet and now finally the time has come
alpha's unleashing her full horde
whisperer negan has quickly risen the
ranks in fact one day she's like hey man
want a bang he's like well it's been a
while i'm in but tell me you're taking
the zombie mask off and she does not so
yeah that happens and now it's time for
the battle of hilltop the commander is
aaron yeah remember nerdy justin
timberlake well he lost a boyfriend then
lost an arm so he's had a drastic
transformation now with a sexy
apocalypse beard and a medieval weapon
for an arm and yeah without guns our
group goes full game of thrones they're
putting up a valiant fight but the
whispers make tree sap bombs and leave
hilltop a smoking ruin after the battle
alpha finally lets her guard down around
which is just what he was waiting for
because negan oh assassinates alpha
sorry girl you're kinda hot but you're
too crazy and he delivers her head to
the person who let him out of a cell
just for this purpose it's carol yeah
this was part of her long game to
finally avenge henry and negan was
hoping to earn some points on his
redemption arc so he could be an
accepted part of the group anyone who
was there will never fully forgive him
but at least they accept he's on their
side for now but alpha had a right-hand
man this giant beta who is an absolute
monster so he rounds up the zombie horde
and is coming for revenge it's the
whisperers round two beta boogaloo he
goes into alexandria with no resistance
our group evacuated to a more defensible
location pretty soon he tracks them down
and so they make their final stand
things look bleak but some
reinforcements arrived who's this crazy
ninja guy in a mask turns out he's a new
friend of maggie yes she's back on the
show it's a long story short daryl kills
beta and they lead the horde off a cliff
the whisperers are defeated but life
goes on there's always new problems
eugene had been reaching out on the
radio looking for other communities and
one day someone answers and it sounds
like a hot girl yeah eugene has a new
radio girlfriend stephanie and they make
plans to meet up so he recruits a few
chaperones into the booty call crew
along the way they meet a zany new
character princess who is a little bit
crazy but very nice and friendly but
eugene's lady love does not arrive
instead our group's ambushed by a bunch
of stormtroopers what they're taken
prisoner by this advanced new group
maggie has some troubles of her own
she's on the run from a group called the
reapers and when she sees that negan is
out of his cell she is not happy about
that because of course he killed her
husband glenn but negan these days seems
to regret all the bad things he did he
wants to be a good guy and so what new
threats will our survivors face in
season 11 how will this journey come to
an end find out on the epic final season
of the walking dead and the best way to
watch this new season of the walking
dead is on amc plus season 11 begins on
august 22nd but the first episode is
dropping a week early on amc plus only
august 15th then watch each new episode
of the intense final season three days
ahead of the sunday air time on thursday
be part of the early crew who's right on
the cutting edge of the walking dead
content stream it from any device ad
free you know the drill this is the best
way to watch so go ahead and click my
link in the description to start your
free trial of amc plus now and join in
for the beginning of the end the final
season of the walking dead
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you love
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member